a zoo has 15 emperor penguins who make
up 30
of the total number of penguins at the
zoo how many penguins live at the zoo
so let's let
x equal the number
of the total number of penguins who live
at the zoo who live at
the zoo so they're telling us that 30 of
that are the emperor penguins which are
15. so they're saying if we take 30
percent so 30 percent of x is equal to
15. or another way of saying this is we
could say instead of writing 30 we could
write that as a decimal as
0.30
of x so
0.30 times x
times x
is equal to
is equal to 15.
and now to solve this we just have to
divide
0.3 or we have to divide both sides by
0.30
so let's do that 0.30
we get
x is equal to 15 divided by
0.30 now that's let's let's do a little
we're going to do a little arithmetic to
solve this one so if we take 0 it's 15
divided by
0.30 so just as a refresher of dividing
decimals we can essentially multiply
both of these by a hundred and when you
multiply both of them by 100 you can't
just multiply one of them then you would
get a different different answer but if
you multiply both of them by 100 you
move this decimal over two spots so it
becomes a 30 and you move this decimal
over two spots so it becomes fifteen
hundred so it really boils down to how
many times the the same number of times
that thirty goes into fifteen hundred is
the number of times that point three
zero will go into fifteen
so let's think about this let me rewrite
here just what's neat 30 goes into 1500
all we did is we moved both decimals
over to the right twice or you could say
we just multiplied the numerator and the
denominator here by 100 which wouldn't
change the value of the fraction
so 30 goes into let's see it doesn't go
into 1 doesn't go into 15 it does go
into 150 goes into 150 5 times 5 times
30 is 150
subtract you get 0 and then 30 goes into
0 0 times so this thirty goes into
fifteen hundred fifty times so this
right over here is equal
is equal to fifty and you can verify it
multiply point three times fifty and you
will get fifteen
now there is another way of doing it
you could say the fraction of emperor
penguins over the total number of
penguins at the zoo so you could say
you could say
you could say 15 over the total number
of penguins at the zoo
is equal to 30 percent percent literally
means 30 hundred so it's equal to
30 for every hundred
it's equal to 30 for every 100 and then
you could solve for this right over here
and a really simple way of doing this is
you say look to go from 30 to 15
you have to divide by 2 if you're going
from the right to the left so let's
divide by 2 right over here so x would
be equal to 50. 15 over 50 is the same
thing as 30 over 100 so the total number
of penguins are 50.